paris total
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat dans un instant nous allons
prendre la direction de l'hémicycle où
les sénateurs poursuivent ce matin
l'examen du projet de loi loppsi 2 ils
ont bientôt terminé l'examen en seconde
lecture de ce texte
le vote devrait donc intervenir en fin
de matinée hier les sénateurs ont voté
la plupart des modifications déjà adopté
par la commission des lois par exemple
ils ont refusé d'étendre les peines
planchers où ils ont souhaité que ce
soit le juge qui se prononce en faveur
d'un couvre feu pour les mineurs de
moins de 13 ans et non pas le préfet en
ce qui concerne l'assouplissement du
permis à points et le sénat n'a pas
souhaité rouvrir le débat ce sont donc
les dispositions votées par les députés
qui ont été adoptées par les membres de
la haute assemblée tout de suite donc
direction l'hémicycle très bonne séance
à tous l'ordre du jour appelle la suite
de discussions deuxième lecture du
projet de loi adopté avec modifications
par l'assemblée nationale en deuxième
lecture d'orientation et de
programmation pour la performance de la
sécurité intérieure dans la discussion
des articles nous sommes parvenus à
l'article 32 ter à la vente hergé un
homme d'abord un amendement numéro 42e
sinon c'est madame thèse qui le dévore
la parole madame oui merci monsieur le
président si vous m'y autorise et je
présenterai l'amendement 42 le 43 en
même temps le 43 et un amendement de
repli par rapport aux 42
en fait vous allez voir que
contrairement à ce qui peut parfois être
dit nous avons de la constance et de la
cohérence dans nos prises de position
puisque l'amendement 42 et donc un
amendement de suppression de l'article
32 ter l'article 32 ter est une
conséquence d'un article de l'article
elles n'ont pas remis d'un article de la
loi de finances du 30 avril 2009 à
laquelle nous nous étions à l'époque
opposé par la voix de madame andrée
nault
michel andré qui prévoyait la
possibilité pour l'état de céder à des
personnes privées et à titre onéreux des
informations nominatives personnelles
qui figure sur les pièces
administratives exigées pour la
circulation des véhicules
aujourd'hui le gouvernement souhaite
revenir un petit peu sur les
possibilités offertes à état en
introduisant la possibilité pour l'état
d'enquêter sur les futurs clients par la
voie des enquêtes administratives
nous supposons donc que s'il ya
nécessité de faire des enquêtes c'est
que sans doute il ya eu des utilisations
abusives ou peut-être même délictueuse
je ne sais pas de ceux de ses
transmissions et de cession à titre
onéreux des fichiers il ya donc un
danger potentiel pour les pour les
personnes qui sans forcément le savoir
parce que l'information manifestement
n'est pas connu du grand public donc ils
sentent sans le savoir permettent à des
entreprises privées d'avoir accès à des
données personnelles les concernant
donc nous demandons le retrait de cet
article 30 ter et à défaut à tout le
moins nous demandons à ce qu'il ne soit
pas possible pour l'état de céder ces
données pour des prospections
commerciales mais de se restreindre aux
données utilisées à des fins d'en quête
éventuellement je profite aussi de ce
que j'ai la parole et que du coup j'ai
été assez consiste pour reposer une
question qui était posée déjà deux fois
hier soir peut-être même trois fois ya
soir mais monsieur ministre s'était pas
vous qui étiez là on n'a pas eu de
réponse donc je réitère la question quid
de l'ordonance de 45 et quelles sont les
intentions du gouvernement en matière de
code pénal des mineurs et de réforme de
cette ordonnance de 1945 je vous
remercie
merci monsieur rapporteur nouveau
écoutant avec prudence ministre deux
amendements sur 42 cet amendement tend à
supprimer l'article 30 ter qui prévoit
qu'une enquête administrative d'être
réalisé s'agissant des personnes qui se
voient accorder le droit de réutiliser
des données de synthèse
d'immatriculation des véhicules
une telle disposition apparue la
commission des lois comme utile pour
éviter d'éventuels abus donc je vais au
gré de mettre un avis défavorable la
suppression de cet article
l'article d'el mandement 43
cet amendement propose de supprimer la
possibilité pour l'état de vendre les
coordonnées personnelles contenues dans
les fichiers de cartes grises des fins
commerciales
l'encadrement de cette pratique est
cependant sérieux et présente article
temps précisément à renforcer les
garanties donc un avis défavorable
jane minutes pour votre avis s'il vous
plaît dans ces deux amendements
défavorable jouait simplement précisé
enfin presque puisque elle m'a interrogé
sur encourager une réflexion en tout cas
où vous donner mon sentiment sur une
réflexion sur la réforme de l'ordonnancé
de 45 sur les mineurs bon d'abord
factuellement j'observe que cette
ordonnance a été modifiée au moins une
dizaine deux fois depuis depuis la
libération et deuxième point je vous
cache pas qu effectivement j'ai des
convictions sur ce sujet mais troisième
point comme vous-même collectivement me
avaient encouragée cela relève de la
compétence judiciaire et vie va de soi
que je me garderai bien d'empiéter sur
celui ci donc ce n'est pas de ma
compétence aujourd'hui que de vous
répondre bien mais ouvriers avec le
sourire tout s'arrange donc avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement je mets aux voileux 40 de
ceux qui sont pour avis contraire pas
adopter même vote je suppose sur le 43
pas adopté et je mets ouvre à l'article
30 taire ceux qui sont pour les blâmes
un avis contraire il est ainsi adopté
non modifié l'article 31 non modifiées
31 quater non modifiée même vote alors
nous arrivons au chapitre 7 leur article
32 ter à nous avons deux amendements
identiques que nous allons appeler tout
d'abord durant des années
mais dira m pas dit si monsieur rien oui
monsieur le président ce miss mes chers
collègues nous arrivons à des articles
les plus emblématiques de
ce texte qui concerne l'évacuation des
campements illicites
il faut rappeler l'origine de cet
article les origines ce sont les
chaleurs de l'été et dans les chaleurs
de l'été présent la république a fait
une déclaration incendiaire plusieurs
déclarations incendiaires mais une en
particulier qui souhaitaient mettre le
feu à toute une communauté qui était la
communauté des roms et la communauté des
gens du voyage
et puis nous avons eu ensuite cette
traduction législative qui a baissé d'un
cran les prétentions élyséenne
mais qui aboutit à un texte qui au fond
cette fois ci vise qui les bidonvilles
les mal lotis les plus mal lotis les
plus mal logés ceux qui habitent dans
des habitations de quatre sous et ce
texte est venu en première lecture
devant le sénat une nouvelle fois
derrière le sénat a fait preuve sans
doute de sa hauteur de vue habituelle
jeudi avec précision en essayant
d'encadrer les dispositions de ce texte
pour autant quel est l'état à définitive
de ce texte il n'est pas fameux parce
que l'origine n'est pas fameuse c'est un
texte dérogatoire sur tous les points
au droit commun il déroge au droit
commun en matière d'expulsions en
principe une expulsion est décidée par
un tribunal
la tribunal ne décidera pas l'expulsion
aura lieu et ensuite après il pourra y
avoir toujours un recours encore faut-il
que les personnes concernées soient au
fait de ce recours et les moyens de se
re coups en tout cas on change le droit
commun qui est en principe une décision
judiciaire voilà on change le droit
commun puisque d'habitude en matière
d'expulsions il ne peut pas y avoir
d'expulsion l'hiver là ces dispositions
ne s'appliqueront pas alors que nous
sommes en présence d'une des populations
les plus défavorisées qui soit ils
changent également le droit commun
puisque en principe une expulsion c'est
une procédure précise ou même le préfet
doit être averti pour qu'il puisse
organiser des solutions de relogement
hélas ce ne sera pas le cas il change de
droit commun puisqu'il permet même la
destruction des biens alors surtout il
ya un point qui nous sommes dans ce
texte c'est que la loi est dure avec ces
personnes sans logis mais une autre loi
qui est celle qui reconnaît le droit
opposable au logement n'est pas
appliquée et nous voici donc dans une
drôle de situation on a voté une loi il
ya quelques années en 2007 maintenant
qui reconnaisse un droit opposable au
logement opposable qui a une noix nous
dit tout les commentaires qui a une
valeur constitutionnelle équipe à
appliquer alors voilà ce qui est
choquant
deux poids deux mesures dites on est là
en fait faudrait-il dire de loi de
mesure et vous me permettrez cette
conclusion c'est peut-être ça qui est
inadmissible dans cette loi selon que
vous soyez puissant ou misérable
la loi vous et dur où la loi vous est
favorable
voilà évidemment en république ce que
nous pouvons pouvons pas accepter
je vous remercie madame à ça si vous
présentez l'amendement ce matin ce matin
ma tombe avant oui merci monsieur le
président nous nous opposons c'est vrai
fermement à l'adoption de cet article
qui crée une nouvelle procédure
procédure d'ailleurs concurrente à celle
des articles 27 et 28 de la loi de mars
2007 qui était relative à la prévention
de la délinquance procédure donne des
vacations d'exception procédure
expéditive et arbitraire pour expulser
les habitants installés de manière
illicite dans des habitats de fortune
donc en plus de neutraliser le pouvoir
des juges puisque elle donne un pouvoir
exorbitant aux préfets ces dispositions
aboutissent en outre un contournement
progressif de l'esprit de la loi sru
adapté en juillet 2007 loi qui nous le
regrettons n'est pas vraiment appliquée
en particulier dans les villes de droite
avaient pourtant pour but d'inciter les
collectivités locales à se doter d'aires
d'accueil pour les gens du voyage afin
de leur permettre de disposer d'un
habitat salubre et conforme à leur mode
de vie
dans le même temps elle permet aux
communes dotées des dac
de pouvoir procéder à des expulsions le
nouveau dispositif propose d'étendre à
toutes les communes la possibilité de
procéder à ces mêmes d'expulsion civile
complètement de son sens la loi de 2000
le recours à la est fortuné lit une
augmentation des situations d'exclusion
par le logement la mise en oeuvre de la
loi dalo étant pour l'instant
insuffisante au regard de l'ampleur de
la crise du logement ainsi que
d'ailleurs le démontrent les tableaux de
bord du comité de suivi dalo de plus cet
article prévoit l'éventualité de la
démolition des habitations ce qui peut
provoquer un risque majeur de violation
du droit de propriété
nombreux sont ceux qui risquent d'être
victimes de cette disposition de prêts
civ
le sdf vivent sous tente ou dans des
cabanes les gens du voyage en voie de
sédentarisation habitants parfois sur
des terrains leur appartenant d'ailleurs
ou qui leur sont concédés mais dans des
locaux sans permis des mobile homes des
gens du voyage qui traversent des
communes et qui refusent de construire
des aires d'accueil qui occuperait ainsi
un habitat alternatif
donc en réalité cet article organise la
flamme à la répression d'une franche de
la plus exclue et la plus précaire de la
population ce soit les sdf
que ce soit ceux qui ont un mode de vie
un peu différent du nôtre et qui sont
quand même considérés comme des
marginaux à la fois par les institutions
et apparemment par ce gouvernement
ainsi donc vous créez une nouvelle
discrimination concernant la protection
du domicile et vous traiter comme des
coupables ce qui en réalité sont les
victimes à la fois de l'incurie de
l'état en matière de logement et en
matière d'accueil
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
votre avis sur ces deux amendements mais
monsieur le président messieurs ministre
c'est un moment visitait supprimer la
procédure spéciale d'évacuation des
camps illicites mise en place par le
présent texte est adopté en première
lecture par le sénat
cette procédure dont la commission des
lois à renforcer les garanties en
première lecture vise à remédier à une a
qu'une de la législation en effet cette
dernière prévoit une procédure
spécifique pour les vacations des
résidences mobiles en cas de
stationnement illégaux
sans prévoir un dispositif comparable
pour l'évacuation des campements
illicites alors même que ceux ci peuvent
présenter les mêmes atteinte à la
salubrité à la tranquillité ou la
sécurité publique donc la commission a
émis un avis défavorable pour ces deux
amendements de suppression
je vais consulter le ministre de
l'intérieur même avis bien monsieur
verizon bande simplement quelques mots
d'explication sur ce texte
c'est plus le président de la commission
nationale consultative des gens du
voyage qui s'expriment que le sénateur
ou les deux si vous voulez je crois que
nous sommes dans un processus
d'amélioration de la situation à
l'adresse des gens qui utilisent des
habitations ou de des caravanes dans
notre pays
le rapporteur vient de rappeler très
justement que la mesure précédente à la
limite pourrait presque être
discriminatoire et qu'il s'agit de
prendre en considération globalement des
situations illégales et sur deux motifs
le premier motif c'est l'insalubrité le
deuxième motif ces troubles à l'ordre
public et que le texte nouveau prévoit
également dans un état de droit la
possibilité de recourir devant le
tribunal administratif
et de demander au juge de dire le bien
fondé de l'évacuation
si elle est ordonnée par le préfet donc
pour en avoir parlé avec les
organisations des gens du voyage crois
que au départ ils se sont inquiétés
aujourd'hui ils ont bien compris cette
mesure n'était pas spécifiquement que
leur adresse et que plutôt que de 2,2
critiqué le système je pense que nous
ferions mieux nous les parlementaires à
l'adresse des élus locaux sur le
territoire et en particulier des mères
ou des présidents d'intercommunalités au
moment où 98 tu descends schémas
départementaux sont en révision de
prendre en considération et d'introduire
dans les schémas départementaux la
réalité que constituent les terrains
familiaux dont et auquel il a été fait
référence c'est-à-dire des gens du
voyage qui ont décidé d'une
sédentarisation ou d'une semi
sédentarisation de se poser quelque part
de trouver les moyens d'assouplissement
à la fois du code de l'urbanisme et de
la présence sur le territoire pour une
meilleure intégration de ces populations
à un moment choisi ou la nouvelle
génération souhaite plutôt une
sédentarisation une semi sédentarisés à
sion il s'agit donc plutôt trouver des
solutions pour les accompagner et moi je
pense que ce texte à l'adresse des
préfets de la possibilité d'aller vers
aider des évacuations
dès lors que sur des points précis et
une situation anormale est à la fois
dénoncée par le maire de la commune et
par la population et de faire entrer
tout le monde dans une situation de
l'égalité c'est quelque chose que l'on
doit y compris ces jours-là bien je vous
remercie donc je vais mettre au revoir
monsieur juste une indication vabre à ce
qui vient d'être dit je suis d'accord
sur ce que je suis et si on veut bien le
dire bien évidemment nous devons tous
effectivement mettre en place les
dispositions que nous implique nous
impose la loi nous devons le faire c'est
non seulement parce que c'est conforme à
la loi mais aussi c'est sans doute notre
devoir moral de le faire bien entendu
mais en même temps n'avancez pas cet
argument juste pour occulter tout
l'autre partie de la loi vous traitez là
des gens du voyage nous savons que ce
texte va bien au delà des gens du voyage
et concerne je le répète les populations
les plus précaires celles qui ont des
habitations éphémère que fait-on pour
ces gens là est ce que pour ces
personnes là qui sont les plus démunis
on doit aboutir à des régimes
dérogatoires pourquoi ne pas appliquer
le droit commun et le droit commun c'est
une décision judiciaire préalable bien
alors je mets aux voix ces deux
amendements identiques ceux qui sont
favorables bien levé la main avis
contraire ils ne sont pas adoptées
maintenant j'appelle trois amendements
qui peut faire l'objet d'une discussion
commune le de rectifier qui vont se
présenter par monsieur moment où le
faire c'est lefebvre de la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues avec votre
autorisation et c'est 2
collègues beaumont je vais couper les
deux présentations en rappelant que donc
il concerne l'occupation illicite du
domicile d'autrui le sénat conscient de
ce problème avait voté en 2007
une disposition qui permettait de saisir
le préfet dans une procédure d'urgence
toutefois cette disposition maintien en
pratique un délai de plusieurs jours
avant que le propriétaire ou locataire
légitime ne puisse récupérer son
logement alors que pour une victime
chaque nuit exclu de son propre domicile
représente un pro mathis mme et des
frais importants
en outre cette disposition est une
pratique rarement appliquée car elle est
très mal connu des forces de l'ordre
suite aux observations justifier de la
commission des lois cet amendement
apporte deux précisions indispensables
par rapport au texte voté par
l'assemblée nationale
tout d'abord il exclut les qu'un permis
par la loi comme dans le premier alinéa
de l'article 226 4 ensuite il vise
occupation du domicile et non pas le
simple séjour ce qui restreint la
disposition au cas où la personne
séjournant illicitement dans le domicile
empêche son propriétaire ou locataire
légitime de rentrer chez lui il ne
semble pas y avoir lu en revanche à
distinguer entre le cas où l'occupation
était illicite
dès le départ ou si elle les deux
devenus par la suite les conséquences
pour le propriétaire ou locataire
légitime étant strictement identiques
mais aussi le 50 de rectifier 15 pièces
c'est monsieur vous oui vous faites le
lien donné et eu ensemble d'accords
merci le 54 rectifier c'est madame
procréation vous avez n'a pas voir merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
effectivement en 2007 avec un certain
nombre d'écoles elle j'ai été à
l'initiative de cet article qui a permis
enfin d'introduire une disposition qui
permettent d expulser les squatteurs qui
s'introduisent dans des domiciles
occupés
je rappelle que cet amendement est cet
article avait été votée à la quasi
unanimité de la droite et de la gauche
puisque nous avions reçu les
associations de squatters organisé entre
guillemets qui sont le droit au logement
et qui sont jeudi noir puisque comme
nous ils dénoncent ces squats qui
pénètre qui sont dans des domiciles de
personnes parties à l'hôpital partis en
vacances et non pas dans les logements
vie
nous sommes donc très contents que cette
disposition existe mais comme me disait
dans notre collègue antoine lefèvre
je suis la première à constater qu'elle
est mal appliquée elle commence tout
juste à être connu par les préfets alors
que là quand même plus de quatre ans
alors l'assemblée nationale avait
introduit une disposition que le sénat
la commission des lois a souhaité
modifier en tenant compte justement des
remarques de la commission des lois
j'ai introduit dans cet amendement le
fait de pénétrer et de séjourner à
titres frauduleux dans le domicile est
aussi la mention or les cas où la loi le
permet pour que justement l'introduction
frauduleuse prouve bien qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un locataire qui ne peut plus
payer et qui est dont le propriétaire
voudrait expulsé il s'agit bien donc des
cas très précis que j'ai signalé tout à
l'heure et j'en ai eus récemment dans ma
commune ou une personne âgée était parti
pendant un mois et demi voir sa famille
et si les voisins n'avaient pas vu le
basson logement était squatté les gens
avaient tout mis sur sur le trottoir
donc c'est pour être un peu plus
efficace par rapport à la disposition de
merci maman va demander l'avis du
rapporteur une se présente sous ministre
ces trois amendements visent à rétablir
la création de l'infraction de vol de
domicile qui a été rejeté par le sénat
en première lecture
adopté à l'assemblée nationale est
supprimée par la commission des lois
si la commission des lois a supprimé
cette disposition c'est que l'objectif
poursuivi est largement satisfait par le
droit en vigueur
en effet non seulement l'article 226-1 4
du code pénal disent d'ores et déjà le
maintien illicites au domicile d'autrui
mais l'article 38 de la loi du 5 mars
2007 instituant le droit au logement
opposable organise une procédure
d'expulsion rapide de l'occupant illégal
du domicile d'autrui qui permet aux
propriétaires
locataire du logement occupé de demander
au préfet de mettre en demeure
l'occupant illégal de quitter les lieux
lorsque la mise en demeure n'a pas été
suivie d'effet le préfet doit procéder à
l'évacuation forcée de l'intéressé cette
procédure est enfermé dans aucun délai
le titulaire du domicile n'ayant qu'à
déposer plate rapporter la preuve que le
logement constitue son domicile et faire
constater l'occupation illicite par un
officier de police judiciaire
elle ne nécessite donc pas de décision
d'expulsion et s'avère plus performante
que l'expulsion pour violation de
domicile en cas de flagrance en outre
s'agissant d'avancement numéro deux il
n'est pas prévu le cas où le maintien
dans le domicile est autorisé par la loi
donc je m'envoie aussi aux signes et
amendements joie de les retirer soit
malheureusement s'il ne retirait pas
je mettrai aucun avis défavorable
monsieur le ministre votre avis si vous
voulez président n'a signé peut y avoir
une nuance avec la commission simplement
j'ai bien écouté ce que vient de dire le
rapporteur je pense que sur le 2
rectifier le 54 rectifier et je partage
l'analyse sur le retrait et parce que le
50 de rectifier lui lui seront sans
doute résumé de manière peut-être qu'une
rédaction qui est plus satisfaisante
l'esprit le maine le même esprit alors
simplement j'ai bien noté que la
commission et mettez souhaité soit lé
retrait soit un avis défavorable
afin de tenir compte de ce qui vient des
t'exprimer moi je m'en remettrai à la
sagesse sur le 52e rectifié on est bien
d'accord
très bien vient alors le de rectifier et
et le maintenu l'an je le retire
il est retrouvé le 54 est ce que vous le
maintenez madame au gardien je vais me
retirer au profit du l'article pour
lequel
le ministre a donné un avis de sa geste
je veux simplement dire à notre
rapporteur qu étant à l'origine de cet
article 38
je peux assurer qu'il n'est pas
appliquée et qu'il ne suffit pas
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois
moi je joue bien le texte est
insuffisant et il faut effectivement
peut-être l'améliorer mais dire qu'un
texte n'est pas appliquée parce qu'il
n'est pas connue et faire un nouveau
texte
ce sera exactement la même chose
franchement moi je trouve quand même
qu'on est on est quand même curieux
parce que vous y ancrer d insécurité
juridique en modifiant tout le temps des
textes et notamment en matière pénale
monsieur le ministre si c'est pas
appliquée on peut faire des circulaires
que je sache à la fois le ministère de
l'intérieur et le ministère de la
justice que le ministère de la justice
ça lui arrive aussi enfin des magistrats
salsa leur arrivée aussi d'oublier qu'on
a voté des lois donc bah oui mais si
c'est pas appliquée parce que ce que
vous ce que vous mais en plus je trouve
que la pression mise par certaines
associations pour dire le parlement fait
pas son travail et cetera
l'antiparlementarisme ça commence à
suffire et qu'on défend pas les braves
gens je trouve que c'est pas ça alors de
deux choses une monsieur me dise ou bien
il faut rectifier le texte et moi je le
conçois peut-être que c'est bien puisque
vous avez donné un avis de sagesse mais
en même temps je trouve déplorable qu'on
vienne dire attendez on a voté une loi
en 2007 qui normalement doit avoir une
efficacité réelle mais personne ne la
connaît on applique pas alors donc enfin
un nouveau texte
le nouveau texte sera exactement la même
chose il ya pas de raison qu ce quoi
qu'ils soient mieux appliquées que le
texte précédent 6,6 ou bien est-ce qu'il
est appliqué oui est ce qu'il est et non
mais madame procas ya vol dit
et en vertu de quoi parce que nous
sommes une association dit ah bon bah
oui mais je crains bien je crains bien
madame ma chère collègue je crains bien
que ce que vous proposez qui pas quand
même très éloigné du texte actuel 1
franchement
1 une amélioration mais alors il aurait
mieux fait il aurait mieux valu veuillez
m'excuser mais on va pas faire du
travail de commission en séance
il fut suffisait peut-être de changer un
mot dans le texte que vous aviez fait
voter en 2007 bien
alors madame laissez moi oui
explications de vote parce que pour une
fois que je peux lire et toujours avec
le sourire monsieur le président je suis
entièrement d'accord avec votre position
quand un texte n'est pas appliquée on en
refait pas un autre on fait appliquer le
texte si si on veut le faire appliquer
et à monsieur le ministre que les
sablons redire ce qu'on regrette nous
sur ces bancs c'est qu'effectivement on
n'a toujours pas la réponse à votre
question sur les mineurs mais parce que
le garde des sceaux lui même n'est pas
venu hier alors qu'il s'agissait de
textes concernant les mineurs c'est tout
donc le 52e rectifiée bien maintenue
bien alors je mêle aux voix il a reçu un
avis défavorable de la commission un
avis de sagesse du gouvernement ceux qui
chantent pour lève la main avis
contraire il est adopté et l'article 32
ter a ainsi modifié même vote
il est adopté chapitre sceptre bis qui
le présente pour le groupe crc
c'est le 110 madame la présidente
bourgoin en ce sens d'ici préfigure ce
qui va venir par la suite puisque nous
ne sommes pas d'accord avec la logique
de tout ce chapitre nous proposons de
supprimer la division avec la commission
défavorable compte tenu de la place
croissante de la police municipale dans
la sécurité quotidienne
quel est l'avis du gouvernement même
avis bien pas d'explication de match je
le mets aux voix ce qui s'en fout relève
la main avis contraire
attendez rla j'ai besoin de compter ceux
qui sont pour lève la main droite de 5,6
ceux qui sont contre
il y avait de l'assouplissement bien il
est adopté
32 ter deux amendements identiques que
monsieur ans gianni vous avez la parole
sur le 45
oui monsieur le président il y à
quelques quelques semaines le
gouvernement nous a proposé une voie sur
2 réforme des collectivités
territoriales et dans cette loi il y
avait quelques articles qui concernait
la clarification des compétences et il y
avait une grande inspiration qui
consistait à dire il faut pas tout
mélanger il faut vraiment que l'on sache
qui fait quoi quelles sont les
différentes collectivités qui doivent
agir avec des blocs de compétences bon
d'accord c'est ce que nous a expliqué au
nom de la lisibilité sans doute aussi de
la compréhension par le citoyen de notre
organisation territoriale mais chose à
dire sans doute de notre organisation de
la république et voilà que détour d'un
texte
tout d'un coup et bien la confusion est
apportée par le même gouvernement et que
l'on dit que la police municipale et
pour cet art clic le son directeur bien
au fond serait une bonne chose qu'il ait
la qualité d'adjoint de fichiers de
police judiciaire et donc qui participe
aux tâches de la police judiciaire en
l'absence de l'officier de police
judiciaire
nous ça nous sommes de la confusion est
en lutte et on voit très bien la raison
la raison c'est que il y a l'état n'a
plus d'argent
l'état a les caisses sont vides et donc
évidemment ce qu'on peut pas financer
avec les moyens de l'état on essaye de
le faire financer d'une façon ou d'une
autre par les collectivités
territoriales nous ne pouvons que nous
opposer à cet article je vous remercie
le sens et qui le présente
oui c'est le même raisonnement que notre
collègues donc avec cet article le donc
le qui octroie le statut d'officier de
police judiciaire aux directeurs des
polices municipales des villes de
comptant plus de 40 agents ça veut dire
qu'il pourra procéder à des arrestations
un conseil aux flagrants délits
constatés les crimes délits et
contraventions établir pour le pv procès
verbal recueillir les renseignements sur
les auteurs et complices d'infraction il
sera même possible de procéder à des
perquisitions
à l'heure actuelle il ya un lien de
subordination le directeur de police
municipale en la qualité d'agent de
police judiciaire adjoint
donc là il s'agit d'élargir le champ
d'action
le directeur des polices municipales or
la présence d'un officier de police
judiciaire comme le concède
monsieur courtois fans entre rapporteur
et de les rendre quasi autonome sans
pour autant prévoir la formation
adéquate revalorisation de traite enfin
le traitement ni une prise en charge par
l'état ce qui est bien effectivement la
question des questions donc qu'est-ce
que il apparaît avec ça c'est l'objectif
de substituer la police municipale à la
police nationale d'un certain nombre de
fonctions et pour des raisons à la fois
budgétaire il peut être bien d'autres et
je nous sommes tout à fait opposé à ce
que n'ouvre la porte du pénal un
fonctionnaire de l'administration
territoriale qui différence de la police
nationale n'a pas la formation en la
matière et donc voilà je pense que ça
mérite réflexion et
c'est assez regrettable que on se
précipite dans ce genre de transfert de
compétences et les charges
merci monsieur le rapporteur votre vie
monsieur préemption ministe pendante
amendement de suppression a déjà été
examinée en première lecture est
d'ailleurs déjà été rejetée l'octroi de
la qualité d'appel j au directoire
police municipale leur permettra d'agir
de manière plus efficace pour préserver
la sécurité dans certaines grandes
villes de france donc un avis
défavorable ces deux amendements
monsieur le ministre de même à vis bien
nana oui merci monsieur le président
c'est un article qui inquiète grandement
les maires qui à mon sens en tout cas
fait preuve soit d'une grande
méconnaissance de ce qui se passe
réellement sur le terrain soit de la
volonté d'avancer à pas feutrés vers
quelque chose encore de nouveau et
encore un transfert de compétences sans
transfert des moyens aux collectivités
territoriales et notamment aux maires ou
peut-être même les deux en effet les
directeurs de police municipale de plus
de 40 agents ne sont jamais sur le
terrain et donc n'exerceront pas c'est
mission d'adjoint de police judiciaire
ne les exerceront pas parce qu'ils ne
sont pas sur le terrain ils sont dans
les bureaux où il exerce bien d'autres
missions
alors pourquoi leur donner ce titre si
l'on exerce par émission si ce n'est
pour demain revenir aux directeurs de
police municipale de 20 agents ou de
disques 2,5 voire après demain tous les
policiers municipaux seront rejoints de
police judiciaire et du coup
effectueront pour le compte de l'état
sur le budget de la collectivité
territoriale
toutes les missions effectivement
afférentes à l'adjointe de police
judiciaire donc bien évidemment nous
sommes fermement opposés et beaucoup de
mères c'était vraiment une disposition
qui suscite beaucoup d'inquiétude chez
les mères beaucoup de maires sont
résolument opposés à cette disposition
merci bien alors je mets aux voix ces
amendements identiques ceux qui sont
pour les glam un avis contraire
ils ne sont pas adoptées et l'article 32
ter n'est pas modifié je pense que c'est
le même
article 32 qu'un pièces d'or mesure
gianni vous avez la parole
oui monsieur brillant choix bref puisque
évidemment l'argumentation de cet
amendement qui concerne cette fois-ci
dépistage d'alcoolémie qui se serait
confiée aux policiers municipaux est la
même que ce que je viens de développer
bien et pour le groupe crc van hamme
bord grande synthe s'il vous plaît oui
la même chose donc je vais pas non plus
développés mais c'est vrai que vous
faites comme si tous les maires étaient
d'accord mais c'est faux beaucoup ne le
sont pas et à juste titre parce que ils
comprennent très bien que derrière ce
type de disposition
d'abord on va pousser les maires à ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas se doter d'une police
municipale et en plus on voit bien que
derrière ça il ya des engagements de
l'état et des risques quand même un
grand de voir des policiers au cal
disons soit politisé soient différentes
les unes des autres
merci monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
bien pour la commission il est
souhaitable de permettre développement
des contrôles d'alcoolémie l'alcool est
un responsable d'une part très nutritifs
des accidents de la route
et je tiens à faire remarquer que la
participation des policiers municipaux
dépistage accalmie se fera sous
l'autorité d'un au pgi donc l'avis
défavorable
deux amendements et quel est l'avis du
gouvernement des paiements même avis
bien madame flèche vous avez la parole
pour expliquer sur de vote
oui juste très rapidement donc les
policiers municipaux seront payés par
les collectivités locales et par les
communes est sous l'autorité dès au pgi
territorialement compétente romandie
gendarmerie nationale et police
nationale je trouve ça regrettable bien
mais c'est la mini pour explication de
vote secret merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre j'ai écouté
beaucoup d'intérêt jirel et ses
interventions j'ai vraiment tout à fait
dans le sens de l'explication de
monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre puisque je n'irai
hier soir on a longuement parlé de la
sécurité routière et j'irai depuis déjà
pas mal d'années les la police
municipale peut-être pas
systématiquement dans dans toutes les
villes mais même dans des petites villes
cinq à dix mille habitants et font aussi
des contrôles de vitesse et en terme de
deux contrôles de vitesse on le voit
quand c'est la gendarmerie nationale et
la police nationale mais on peut
l'appliquer c'est un pli câble
maintenant donc avec pour la police
municipale corps ya un excès de vitesse
tout conducteur est soumis à un contrôle
d'alcoolémie
donc je crois que c'est réellement aussi
une continuité une pour être cohérent
vraiment avec le le système et avec la
lutte contre l'insécurité routière et je
crois que ce niveau là
je crois que c'est c'est tout à fait
l'explication de monsieur le ministre et
du rapporteur vont réellement dans dans
ce sens pour vraiment faire au maximum
en termes de sécurité routière et liées
justement c'est ces dépistages
d'alcoolémie et con qu'on partage tout à
fait le gros merci bien je mets aux voix
ces deux amendements identiques section
pour veulent bien le manifestèrent
levant la main si avis contraire ils ne
sont pas adoptées et l'article n'est pas
modifié article 32 70 s donc là j'ai un
amendement 113 madame la présidente
bravo quand vous avez la parole oui
merci
nous proposons de supprimer cet article
qui tente alourdir l'obligation pour nos
concitoyens de se soumettre à des
fouilles de leur sac ou bagages comme
qu'ils participent à une quelconque
manifestation culturelle sportive ou
récréative
cette obligation existait déjà mais
elles visaient les grands rassemblements
de plus de 1500 personnes
or l'article 32 70 s abaisse le seuil à
300 personnes
en outre il est prévu d'autoriser les
agents de surveillance de paris a
procédé à de telles fouilles
alors qu'il ne devrait pas être
habilités à exercer cette tâche
le fait d'avoir ajouté qu'ils étaient
chargés d'un service de police ne change
rien c'est la justification on emploie
des mots pour justifier ce qu'on veut
faire mais ça sonne ça n'est pas le cas
et donc nous sommes tout à fait contre
ces dispositions
un monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
s'il vous plaît puis cet amendement est
contraire à la position de la commission
en effet les contrôles effectués lors
des manifestations sportives récréatives
culturelles sont un élément essentiel la
sécurité lors de ces événements donc un
avis défavorable à cet amendement de
suppression et vous monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie bien
dans mon explication de vote donc ceux
qui sont pauvres lève la main avis
contraire il n'est pas à voter l'article
30 de ses pièces n'est pas modifié
l'article 39 pièce je n'ai pas
d'amendement suppression maintenu
chapitre 8 moyens matériels et services
nous arrivons à l'article 33 ans j'ai un
amendement du gouvernement
ce mini si vous voulez le présenter le
157 c'est un amendement très technique
ebay propose de repousser au 31 décembre
2013 et la date limite jusqu'à lequel
jusque-là juge la date limite jusqu'à à
laquelle les conseils généraux pouvaient
s'ils le désiraient construire acquérir
ou rénover des bâtiments destinés à être
mise à disposition des dix la
disposition actuelle avait été prévue
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2010 il est proposé
donc de le reporter de trois ans
monsieur le rapporteur
donc la commission n'a pas examiné cet
amendement mais à titre personnel je
suis très favorable effectivement à cet
amendement bien ça permet au département
d'investir
voilà très bien parfait là est ce qu'il
ya des avis contraire
les abstentions il est adopté l'unité
bien merci et l'article 33 également
chapitre 9 dispositions diverses
37 des non modifiées nous arrivons 37 kg
s à 1 là nous avons un amendement c'est
madame associe qui va nous le présenter
à la barre
monsieur le président simplement si vous
savez qu'on ne cautionne pas le
basculement de compétence de la police
nationale vers la police municipale donc
a fortiori nous ne pouvons cautionner
l'octroi de la qualité d'agent de police
judiciaire un stagiaire de la police
nationale qui n'a même pas fini d'être
formés sous prétexte de faire des
économies
nous pensons que vous allez encore un
peu trop loin il est en effet
inadmissible de troyer les
responsabilités inhérentes à ce statut
sans que la formation complète qui est
associé lui et été
dispensée c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous demandons la suppression de cet
article à vie les commissions
c'est donc effectivement un amendement
de suppression de l'article 37 cet
article effectué une coordination
nécessaire et cas prérogatives des
gendarmes avis défavorable quel est le
but du gouvernement même avis alors je
le mets aux voix ce qui sans poudre lève
la main avis contraire il n'est pas
adoptée et l'article qu'un piège n'est
pas modifié quand pièce à 37 qu'inquiet
ah ah
maintenant nous sommes au 37 qu'inquiets
ce b nous avons trois amendements
identiques le 47 75 et le 147 rectifié
j'appelle monsieur anthony pour 147
oui monsieur le président cet article
pose une question de principe
faut-il ou non un droit dérogatoire en
matière de d'étrangers c'est une
question de principe et on voit bien la
réponse qui est apporté là nous avons
une décision du conseil constitutionnel
du 8 décembre 2005 qui traitait de la
récidive matière pénale qui nous a dit
de façon très explicite que la pose d'un
bracelet électronique surveillance
électronique mobile ne pouvait être
décidée que par une décision judiciaire
ça c'est le droit commun si on fait de
la surveillance électronique c'est une
décision judiciaire voilà ce qui doit
être appliqué dans notre pays
quelles que soient les infractions
quelles que soient les personnes dès
l'instant que nous avons à faire à
l'infraction est là et bien là nous
passons à autre chose je vois pas
d'ailleurs son demande tout cela et même
l'opportunité tout ça est bien là nous
nous allons basculer
et puisqu'il s'agit d'un étranger alors
on appliquera pas le droit propre aux
français qu'ils peuvent avoir commis des
crimes tout à fait aussi effroyable que
cet étranger là où même d'ailleurs
participé à des actes de terrorisme
comme comme un étranger mais là puisque
c'est un étranger c'est pas le même
droit
c'est plus une décision judiciaire ça
doit être une décision administrative
franchement je ne vois pas l'opportunité
je vous le dit le monsieur ministre
je vois même pas l'intérêt pratique et
je vois par contre évidemment le fait
que ça contrarie fortement notre droit
commun et qu'à mon avis d'ailleurs pour
cette raison ces dispositions est
inconstitutionnelle bahamas asie oui
monsieur le président cet article est
lui aussi issu d'un des amendements du
gouvernement destiné à durcir le projet
de loi nous nous proposons de le
supprimer et pour plusieurs raisons tout
d'abord
nous pensons qu'il ne suffit pas
d'accoler le qualificatif de terroriste
pour qu'il soit permis de contourner la
loi ou de justifier toute aggravation
pénale cet article prévoit en effet que
le placement sous surveillance
électronique mobile pourra être
prononcée par l'autorité administrative
pour une durée allant de trois mois à
deux ans à l'encontre donc d'un étranger
frappé d'une mesure d'interdiction
judiciaire ou d'expulsion en raison
d'activités à caractère terroriste
je voudrais rappeler ici la décision du
conseil constitutionnel du 8 décembre
2005 qui dit ceci d'une part c'est
l'autorité judiciaire qui prend cette
décision après un débat contradictoire
avec intervention de l'avocat donc vous
supprimez donc le contrôle du juge
en le mettant cette fois encore à
l'écart et d'autre part dans la décision
du conseil constitutionnel il est prévu
donc enfin il est dit que l'accord de
l'étranger concerné est obligatoire en
outre le manquement aux obligations de
placement sous surveillance électronique
mobile pourra être sanctionné d'un an de
prison dans ces conditions il est
évident que cet article rétabli une
double peine pour des étrangers
concernés donc je crains qu une fois de
plus vous preniez prétexte du terrorisme
pur allait élargir encore et encore le
port du bracelet électronique à des
situations de plus en plus diverse et
finalement que vous fassiez de
l'exception la norme
on pourrait se poser la question
effectivement à quand le bracelet
électronique pour tous les étrangers
sans papiers puisqu'il est manifeste que
cet article entretien un amalgame entre
immigration et délinquance
les sociétés de surveillance privée ne
s'en plaindrait pas puisque l'article
lui-même précise que le contrôle à
distance peut être confiée à une
personne de droit privé plus globalement
cet article participe aussi d'un
déplacement de l'utilisation du bracelet
lequel devient simple outil de contrôle
et de surveillance et en aucun cas
un outil de réinsertion et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous vous demandons
de supprimer cet article
merci madame monsieur madame laborde
pour mozart monsieur le président mes
chers collègues nous souhaitons nous
aussi la suppression de cet article qui
généralise le placement sous
surveillance électronique mobile des
étrangers faisant l'objet d'une mesure
d'interdiction ou d'expulsions résultant
d'actes de terrorisme ne pouvant être
mis à exécution en confiant son prononcé
à l'administration et non plus aux juges
et en supprimant l'exigence d'un accord
de la personne ces deux derniers points
contre vienne à la décision du conseil
constitutionnel du 8 décembre 2005 qui
subordonnait le prononcé du pse m à une
décision de l'autorité judiciaire
après débat contradictoire et présence
d'un avocat et à l'accord de la personne
intéressée
il est de plus inadmissible que
l'exécution de la décision puisse être
confiée à une personne privée
même sous le contrôle de
l'administration
monsieur le rapporteur oui monsieur
présents messieurs ministre
abandonnant 47 supprime l'article 37
points qui s b qui prévoit le placement
sous surveillance électronique mobile
des étrangers frappé d'une mesure
d'interdiction judiciaire ou d'expulsion
en raison d'activités à caractère
terroriste
les auteurs de l'amendement conteste en
particulier la compétence de l'autorité
administrative pour décider d'un tel
placement
cependant dans la mesure où il
appartient à l'autorité administrative
de décider de décider de l'assignation à
résidence
il apparaît logique endroit par
parallélisme des formes de confier
également à cette autorité
la responsabilité de décider d'un
placement sous surveillance électronique
qui est une alternative cette
assignation à résidence
en outre les décisions prises par
l'autorité administrative seront
soumises au contrôle juridictionnel de
droit commun en particulier le référé
liberté fondamentales prévues par
l'article l 521 2 du code de justice
administrative avis défavorable il en
est de même pour les amendements 115 et
147 rectifier monsieur le ministre
le président je rappelle tout de même
monsieur anziani et madame pardon madame
assas ici où il est intervenu et que
nous ne parlons pas d'étrangers en
situation irrégulière de droit commun
mais bien de terroristes ce n'est donc
pas tout à fait la même chose et il
arrive vous le savez que des terroristes
faisant l'objet d'une interdiction du
territoire national ou d'une mesure
d'expulsion ne puisse pas être éloignés
immédiatement notre territoire ce qui
explique cette mesure c'est pour cela
que je suis totalement défavorable à
votre amant bien merci
alors je vais mettre aux voix ces
amendements ce risqué des explications
de vote non ceux qui sont favorables
bien levé la main les avis contraire ils
n'en sont pas adoptées maintenant nous
avons deux amendements qui vont faire
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 148
rectifié de monsieur les hacmen à bord
va présenter et le 48 millions d'années
monsieur le président c'est un
amendement de repli qui subordonne le
prononcé du placement sous surveillance
électronique mobile à une décision de
l'autorité judiciaire
mais ce monsieur denis mêmes
explications mais souriant en fait je
vous remercie monsieur l'emportèrent
alors sur les trois amendements sur le
148 et le 48e pour les mêmes raisons que
j'ai donné tout à l'heure pour les
autres amendements nous sommes
défavorables à ces deux amendements
alors d'accord monsieur le ministre mais
ma vie que la commission et pour le
sénat ceux qui sont pour les blés mains
sur la manette 148 et 48 avis contraire
ils ne sont pas adoptées et maintenant
ces mêmes d'abord vous présenter le 149
rectifier alors nous nous replions plus
en plus et nous demandons donc c'est un
amendement de repli qui subordonne le
prononcé du placement sous surveillance
électronique mobile a minima à l'accord
de la personne intéressée
merci monsieur le rapporteur sur
l'amendement 149 c'est tellement prévoit
que le placement sous surveillance
électronique est soumis à l'accord
préalable de l'étranger le sénat avait
lors de la création du psg om par la loi
du 2 décembre 2005 sur le traitement de
la récidive des infractions pénales posé
le principe du consentement de la
personne à son placement sous
surveillance électronique
il n'est pas justifié de prévoir ici
sinon il se trouvera en placement
d'office doc avis favorable merci
monsieur le ministre sur le sang sur le
149 rectifier le ministre vous avez la
parole
monsieur le président écoutez peut-être
ai-je mal compris j'espère dire j'ai mal
compris et votre proposition semble-t-il
c'est finalement de subordonner le port
du bracelet électronique
ça reviendra ça peut-être ai-je mal
compris à l'accord de l'étranger
concerné si c'est ça que pour vous
suivre donc j'émets un avis totalement
défavorable
monsieur le président la commission moi
je comprends mais je rappelle que
normalement la règle c'est l'assignation
à résidence est oui et ou bien c'est une
assouplissement main signe de
l'assignation à résidence parce que
l'assignation à résidence à venir vous
n'êtes pas le droit de sortir et si vous
sortez etc
si vous ne respectez pas les menaces à
des conséquences judiciaires
mais comme en matière judiciaire
il ya l'accord puisque c'est une
modalité d'exécution un assouplissement
monsieur le ministre c'est pas c'est pas
un contrôle l'autre c'est une forme de
d'assignation à résidence gérée tir
mobile comme le fait d'être en détention
et puis d'avoir l'autorisation c'est une
forme d'exécution d'une donc je crois va
nettement mais c'est pour vous rendre
service monsieur le ministre c'est que
effectivement ces personnages ou bien
vous les assignés à résidence ou bien a
dit écoutez on peut assouplir merci on
l'a on vous met le le bracelet
électronique mobile mais ça ne peut pas
être uniquement le bracelet électronique
mobile
c'est en fait si l'assignation à
résidence
peut être assouplie en fait c'est ça
parce qu'autrement détourne complètement
le ski et le bracelet électronique
mobile en matière judiciaire et nous
sommes tenus monsieur le ministre puis
je me permets de vous rappeler par des
décisions du conseil constitutionnel
extrêmement précise donc c'est pas du
tout par par cbc par cohérence vis-à-vis
de ce qui existe en matière de bracelet
électronique et de bracelet électronique
mobile dans le domaine judiciaire
on peut pas aller au delà pour dans le
domaine administratif qu'on va dans le
domaine judiciaire c'est la seule raison
pour laquelle la commission a donné un
avis favorable à l'amendement de
monsieur mézard et de ses collègues le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois
d'abord un je suis naturellement
sensible par définition fait que vous
souhaitiez aider la position du
gouvernement sur ce point mais pardon de
vous lire vous ne démente et donc pas ce
que je viens d'indiquer à savoir que tu
en veux
avec ce dispositif vous demander
l'autorisation à la personne concernée
ou son sentiment son accord pour le port
du bracelet c'est donc ça dépend donc de
sa bonne volonté ou pas bien alors sur
le sens car rectifier si j'ai bien
compris la commission est favorable et
le gouvernement est défavorable ne bien
d'accord donc je passe je passe au 20è
ce qui est des demandes d'explications
de vote
j'en vois pas je le mets aux voix le 149
rectifier ce qui sont pour les blâmes un
avis contraire il est adopté et
l'article 37 qu'inquiets ce b ainsi
modifier également
ensuite l'article 30 16 qu'un kg sc nous
avons trois amendements identiques
monsieur andré ni vous défendez le 49
s'il vous plaît oui monsieur le
président l'article prévoit de
sanctionner d'un an d'emprisonnement le
manquement aux obligations de
présentation périodique aux services de
police et de gendarmerie des étrangers
et nous considérons que cette
disposition n'a pas grand chose à voir
avec ce texte d'orientation de
programmation pour la performance de la
sécurité intérieure qu'ils devraient se
rattacher à la loi que nous en mai
examinée dans une dizaine de jours sur
l'immigration donc nous demandons sa
suppression en la suppression de cet
article
madame associe le sens s il vous plait
oui même logique que mon collègue nous
nous pensons qu'il s'agit là d'un
cavalier législatif dont la présence
n'est absolument pas justifiée il l'a
rappelé nos collègues à l'assemblée
nationale ont examiné le texte relatif à
l'immigration et nous allons le faire
ici même dès dès le 2 février
moi je pense que un an d'emprisonnement
pour ne pas avoir respecté une mesure
d'éloignement du territoire et ben c'est
purement et simplement
impensable donc en présence donc il
serait de bon ton que vous cessiez
d'instrumentaliser les étrangers à des
fins électoralistes condamnables puisque
vous le savez bien il ne consiste qu'à
faire les yeux doux
un parti politique qui s'appelle le
front national merci madame laborde le
150 rectifier alors ce curieux article
nous est soumis dans le cadre de la
loppsi quelques semaines avant que nous
examinions en effet le projet de loi sur
l'immigration où il aurait dû être
discutée
comprenne qui pourra mais surtout il
alourdit les obligations pesant sur les
étrangers faisant l'objet d'une mesure
d'éloignement du territoire national
pour des motifs d'ordre public
il sanctionne les manquements aux
obligations présentation périodique au
service de police ou de gendarmerie qui
permettent de s'assurer que l'individu
reste localisable envie de la mise en
exécution de la mesure d'éloignement
lorsqu'elle deviendra possible pour
parler concrètement cet article
rétablissant le dire une forme de double
peine que le président de la république
avait pourtant supprimé la main sur le
coeur c'est pourquoi nous en demandons
la suppression si monsieur le rapporteur
ces trois amendements pour but de
supprimer l'article prévoyant de
sanctionner des étrangers faisant
l'objet d'une mesure d'éloignement qui
ne respecteraient pas leurs obligations
présentation périodique au seuil de
police gendarmerie
cette disposition comme cependant une
lacune de notre droit il a semblé très
utile de la commission des lois de la
conservez donc d'avis défavorable sur
cet amendement
monsieur mise même avis bien alors je
vais mettre aux voix les trois
amendements ceux qui sont favorables
veulent bien levé la main
est ce qu'il ya des avis contraire
ils ne sont donc pas adoptée et
l'article 37 qu'inquiets ce n est pas
modifiée
nous arrivons à l'article 37 nonies deux
amendements identiques de monsieur en
diani et du gouvernement
c'est madame claeys qui défend le
gouvernant qu'il présente à mon nom je
défends pas le gouvernement mais en
l'occurrence il semblerait qu'on ait une
position commune sur cet article qui
concerne le transfert des fonds
de l'union des anciens combattants de la
police et des professionnels de la
sécurité intérieure dont on souhaite que
ça que ce transfert ne bénéficient pas
de dérogation par rapport au droit
actuel même si c'est effectivement
possible
nous considérons qu'il faut le garantir
le transfert de ces fonds vers une autre
structure mutualiste ou au fonds
national de garantie des mutuelles merci
monsieur le ministre s'est voulu
présenter le 59
en réalité c'est même amendement ce qui
signifie donc paraissait de manière
réciproque que je soutiens le groupe
socialiste mais c'est vrai que ces
dispositions et a pour objectif
d'assurer autorisé l'association union
des anciens combattants de la police et
des professionnels de la sécurité
intérieure à dissoudre sa mutuelle ans
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des évolutions le
rapporteur me le rappelle il ya quelques
instants
mais le gouvernement donc maintient sa
position estime que cette dérogation au
droit commun applicable à la dissolution
des mutuelles mais inspirée par aucun
motif d'intérêt général suffisant donc
donc moi c'est l'amendement 59 du
gouvernement mais qui reprend les mais
les termes de l'amendement
demain place monsieur le rapporteur
maison commune de dio mme smith et une
nombreuses évolutions dans les derniers
jours aussi la commission des lois s'en
est remis à la sagesse du sénat bien et
donc le ministre est favorable avant
monde yannick mille kits et d'anti
quotien donc sagesse du sénat
le sénat est unanime à adopter ces
amendements il n'y a pas d'opposition
pas d'abstention
il en est ainsi décidé et l'article 30
de nos nièces est supprimé
article 30 16 une des siestes alors
monsieur madame plaisent excusez moi oui
merci monsieur le président en ce qui
concerne les paragraphes 1 et 2 de cet
article dont nous demandons la
suppression global il intéresse
l'organisation judiciaire et ne présente
pas de lien direct avec le projet de loi
c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons qu'ils
soient supprimés cet article les mesures
proposées relance également le débat sur
la double peine ap les peines
complémentaires mais en fait double
peine il existe déjà tout l'arsenal
nécessaire aujourd'hui par rapport aux
crimes pour mettre des peines
complémentaires
il existe la déchéance l'incapacité ou
le retrait d'un droit etc
donc nous considérons qu'il est
totalement inutile de faire de nouveau
cet appel du pied au discours du front
national et demande donc le retrait de
l'article bien madame à ça si c'est vous
qui le présentait non c'est un battant
je m'excuse présenter le monsieur le
président l'article 50 de la charte
européenne des droits fondamentaux de
l'union européenne rappelle que nul ne
peut être poursuivi ou puni pénalement
en raison d'une infraction pour laquelle
il a déjà été acquitté ou condamné dans
l'union par un jugement pénal définitif
conformément à la loi donc encore vous
fallait-il essayer de contourner ce
principe et permettre ainsi
l'instauration d'une peine
complémentaire pour les étrangers
reconnus coupables de crimes selon vous
c'est une peine complémentaire
mais selon nous cela s'apparente quand
même à la double peine cet article de
cette peine complémentaire
d'interdiction du territoire existe déjà
d'ailleurs en droit français puisque le
code de procédure pénale dans son
article 3 162 donne déjà aux cours
d'assises la possibilité de prononcer
cette peine complémentaire donc sait-on
que cet article est donc inutile et ne
répondent que d'un objectif de
communication et je crois que ça n'a
qu'une visée
démagogique c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous en demandons purement et
simplement la suppression
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
wheeler pour l'amendement 51 le 1 de cet
article est introduit par notre
assemblée et voter en termes identiques
par les députés il vise à simplifier les
règles de désignation de la cour
d'assises chargée de connaître en appel
des affaires de criminalité organisée
quant aux grands 2 il vise à contraindre
les cons d'assises à se prononcer sur le
droit au séjour d'un étranger reconnu
coupable d'un crime dans le respect du
droit en vigueur
ces deux dispositions donc pleinement
leur place dans le présent projet de loi
en améliorant l'efficacité des
dispositifs en vigueur avis défavorable
aux 51 et par analogie avis défavorable
1 117 istres votre avis même avis bien
alors je le mets au voile et méo voit
ceux qui sont favorables bien levé la
main avis contraire ils ne sont pas
adoptées et l'arctique n'est pas
modifier l'article 37 des siens
suppression maintenu l'article 39
modifiée non modifiées par dont 39 bis
non modifiés maintenant 39 bis b g deux
amendements identiques j'appelle madame
assassi coordination d'accord et madame
laborde
il est dit lente et coordination je nous
vois quel est l'avis de la commission
la coordination et le gouvernement
également donc il n'est pas ils ne sont
pas adoptées par bien merci et l'article
39 bis n'est pas modifié ensuite
l'article 39 bis ces deux amendements
identiques le 110 même chose
coordination donc même vague je suppose
pas d'objection on en est ce que ça va
tellement vite que ce siège
ouanna mais maintenant j'ai le sens 53
ans rectifié de madame laborde madame
laborde nous tomber sur le charme de
votre président mais parce que je lui
donner quelques explications à les 153
rectifier donc c'est aussi un amendement
de coordination avec nos amendement de
repli déposé à l'article 37 37 kg s b
posions la commission identique
identique donc il n'est pas adapté et le
150 rectifié paris mais mes shows à 6
mais il est de mon devoir de vous poser
la question l article 39 bis et attend
les données à huy le premier oui le 154
rectifier vous y êtes favorable par
coordination est par contre c'est le sol
153 est défavorable et donc même boîte
que tout à l'heure et le 150 rectifié de
madame laborde la la commission est
favorable et le gouvernement
également bon donc par coordination et
donc je le mets aux voix pour la clarté
ceux qui sont favorables à la main
unanimité
il est adopté bien parce que c'est fini
le 44 mille suppressions maintenue nous
en arrivons au 44 tête il y à un
amendement 120 qui le défend
coordination donc défavorable
gouvernement défavorable et donc le
sénat est contre on est bien d'accord et
l'article 44 terre n'est pas modifié
j'arrive 45 terre pas d'amendement non
modifiées après l'article 45 terre nous
avons un 67 rectifier c'est monsieur
lefebvre qui le représente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le présent
amendement précise les modalités dans
et en vigueur dans le temps des
nouvelles règles contenues dans
l'article 28 bis afin de conforter la
sécurité juridique du dispositif
ainsi il est proposé d'appliquer les
nouvelles dispositions aux infractions
commises ou devenue définitive à compter
du 1er janvier 2011
merci mesure un bonheur cette position
est effectivement très nécessaire donc
qu'elle est favorable
ouais d'accord et monsieur le ministre
monsieur mais c'est également favorable
donc je mets au voile amendement 67
rectifier ce qui est des demandes
d'explications de vote
je n'en vois pas ce qu'ils sont pour les
flamands est-ce qu'ils aient des avis
contraire il est adopté
maintenant les autres dispositions de ce
projet de loi ne font pas l'objet d'une
deuxième lecture
je vais mettre voir l'ensemble du projet
de loi et y at il des demandes
d'explication madame assassine madame
claisse van hamme bordeaux c est madame
laborde et pour le moment c'est bien bon
madame assas et oui merci monsieur le
président donc l'examen de la loppsi ii
ici en seconde lecture
je dirais à confirmer votre peu dans
klein au débat et combien votre bilan en
matière de sécurité est accablant et que
ce faisant pour faire pour faire bonne
figure sans doute vous ne cessez de
multiplier des lois sécuritaires souvent
inapplicables faut particulièrement de
moyens donc vous avez supprimé la police
de proximité vous asphyxiez
budgétairement les dispositifs de
prévention et de réparation de la
délinquance tout en sueur peuplant les
prisons les transformant ainsi en
véritable école du crime
dans le même temps vous inciter à la
multiplication de la vidéosurveillance
pour le plus grand profit des sociétés
de sécurité privées dont même si
certains continuent à allauch réfuté
l'efficacité est loin d'être prouvé
notamment en termes d'élucidation tout
ceci bien évidemment en supprimant
par milliers des postes de policiers de
terrain les remplacent les remplaçant
par des unités mobiles déterritorialisé
qui comme les carabiniers d'offenbach
arrive toujours trop tard faute de
connaître le terrain
quant au développement des polices
municipales leur existence vous sert de
prétexte pour réduire les effectifs dans
les commissariats et par ailleurs cette
existence pénalise financièrement les
citoyens puisqu'il se voit taxé par deux
fois une fois par l'impôt sur le revenu
total un pollock l'autre par l'impôt
local pour une même mission qui je tiens
à leur rêve réaffirmer ici doit rester
une mission régalienne de l'état donc
force est de constater que vous décidez
sur la sécurité la justice mais aussi
sur d'autres sujets d'abandonner nos
concitoyens de consacrer les moyens de
la puissance publique à la protection
des puissants en creux
votre message est limpide chacun pour
soi et si vous voulez de la sécurité et
bien débrouillez vous pour vous la payer
pour notre part nous continuerons à
travailler l'idée selon laquelle la
sécurité des biens et des personnes est
un droit qui mérite d'autres mesures que
les vôtres d'autant que celle ci
persiste à nier que le combat contre les
violences passe aussi par moins de
précarité de chômage de masse des jeunes
en faisant jouer à nouveau à l'école son
rôle d'ascenseur social en assurant à
tous l'égalité d'accès aux services
publics aux l'emploi au logement à la
culture à la justice etc
alors bien évidemment cela demande plus
de services publics moderniser en
particulier pour l'enfance et la petite
enfance pour l'aide à la parentalité
pour la justice la formation l'éducation
le sport la culture donc plus d'argent
pour les hommes et moi pour les marchés
financiers
je crois qu on en est bien loin avec la
loppsi 2 essayé pour cette raison que
nous rejeter ce texte
oui merci monsieur le président je vais
commencer par rendre hommage à aux
techniques de communication parfaitement
efficace est en tout cas très subtil du
gouvernement en matière de sécurité
il convient d'abord d'affirmer avec
force que la politique menée par le
gouvernement en la matière est efficace
et que la délinquance diminue
et puis à chaque fait divers plus ou
moins monté en épingle
finalement on admet que la délinquance
est quand même pas tout à fait contenu
mais on le justifie c'est pas de la
faute de la politique menée actuellement
mais c'est simplement à cause des
magistrats qui sont lac si c'est à cause
du code pénal qui n'est pas suffisamment
répressif donc à grand renfort de
couverture médiatique on envoie
finalement quoi des renforts humains sur
place et on continue d'augmenter la
défiance du citoyen par rapport à
l'institution judiciaire notamment
et de justifier le fait que nos textes
ne sont pas assez et répressif
finalement les contrevenants sont tous
des dangereux criminels et les juges
sont tous des gens qui les laisse faire
le citoyen a un sentiment d'insécurité
qui croient et ça justifie une fois de
plus en boucle non plus qu en boucle en
spirale les accumulations de textes
pourtant tous totalement inefficace on
en a la preuve auquel on assiste tout
ces dernières années et alors que
traitement et prévention de la
délinquance nécessiterait pourtant et
c'est ce que vous avez écrit dans ce
texte un véritable partenariat
une véritable travail main dans la main
et en confiance entre toutes les
différentes institutions où tous les
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
c'est le contraire que vous faites et
que vous affirmez tous les jours face à
nos concitoyens ce texte on l'a déjà dit
est un fourre-tout ne programme rien du
tout sur le long terme si ce n'est à mon
sens la mise à mal de notre démocratie
et de notre sécurité ce qui est quand
même regrettable pour un texte de
programmation pourquoi d'abord il est
inégalitaire
ne serait ce que par le transfert on en
a parlé ce matin des missions de l'état
vers les polices municipales les
communes riches pourront avoir une
police municipale et une prévention la
délinquance plus ou moins efficaces pas
les communes pauvres les
policiers municipaux sous l'autorité du
méat travailleront pour assumer une fois
plus des fonctions régaliennes qui
devrait revenir à l'état
la formation des policiers municipaux le
président de la commission des lois
n'est plus là mais ne sera pas assurée
en regard des nouvelles missions qui
leur seront confiées
le cnfpt que je sache n'est pas en
mesure aujourd'hui d'assurer cette
mission de formation complète par
rapport à des missions supplémentaires
inégalitaire car la répartition des
forces de sécurité ce fait se fera avec
la désertion des zones rurales c'est
écrit partout dans le texte on va mettre
les forces de sécurité sur les bassins
de délinquance
on va oublier nos zones rurales la
gendarmerie nationale est encore là ce
sont encore des militaires on peut
encore compter sur eux mais ils sont de
moins en moins nombreux en termes
d'effectifs
ils sont aujourd'hui rassemblés avec la
police nationale sous l'autorité du
ministère de l'intérieur ils iront eux
aussi demain s'ils restent là s'ils sont
toujours parmi nous ils ont eux aussi
demain vers les zones urbaines
s'il était encore parmi nous je crois
que coluche nous dirait aujourd'hui que
certains sont plus équivalent que
d'autres hauts lieux de plus égaux ce
texte est inutile voire dangereux
comme je viens de le dire ils organisent
la défiance et déstabilise institutions
judiciaires qui est pourtant un pilier
fondamental en matière de lutte contre
la délinquance
il met à mal le principe de la
personnalisation de la peine qui devient
une dérogation au droit commun ils
organisent un transfert et non pas une
coproduction de l'obligation de sécurité
transfert aussi vers l'essai de sociétés
privées sans mettre en place en amont
les moyens de contrôler et de formation
nécessaire même le domaine public
même le domaine public sera demain sous
le contrôle des sociétés de sécurité
privées grâce à l'outil vidéo
surveillance qui pour moi est un outil
pour vous et d'une fin en elle-même
dogmes le dogme de la perfection de cet
outil est excessivement dangereux et
empêche de mettre en oeuvre les moyens
nécessaires pour le contrôler ce texte
mettant enfin en place
insidieusement les conditions d'une
censure de la communication en
s'abritant derrière la nécessaire lutte
contre la pédopornographie qui est déjà
dans ce texte associé au radicalisme
religieux
voit bien d'ici ce qu'on va me dire
alors il faut pas lutter contre la
pédopornographie
il faut pas lutter contre le radicalisme
religieux si bien sûr mais en conservant
en s'appuyant sur les principes de notre
démocratie
et ce n'est pas être angélique de 10
rondes vrai qu'on a les moyens de lutter
contre ces deux fléaux sans mettre à mal
la démocratie et sans censurer tous les
moyens de communication bref une série
de mesures qui en plus ne vise que les
exécutants de la délinquance jamais les
donneurs d'ordres jamais ce qui tire
vraiment les ficelles des profits
gigantesques liés à la délinquance
paradis fiscaux pisco fraude de grande
envergure système financier bank 1
parfois peu scrupuleuses aucune
aggravation de peine des prescriptions
délai de prescription qui se diminue
aucun moyen dédié spécifiquement à cette
lutte
bref monsieur le ministre vous l'avez
compris nous sommes persuadés que vous
ne vous attaquez pas à la délinquance
mais c'est encore une politique de
communication et un discours populiste
auquel nous ne pouvons nous associer
madame la présidente borvo cohen seat
pour une explication de vote oui merci
monsieur le président moi je vois là il
ya un premier point qui nous paraît
absolument inadmissible c'est que
loin d'eux sous couvert d'une adaptation
de nos textes aux nouvelles formes de
délinquance
le gouvernement continue exactement de
la même façon en aggravant encore les
peines les la répression sans une
analyse sérieuse des effets des
multiples lois précédentes ne serait-ce
que la loppsi 1
il ya des rapports à venir en cours
le monsieur le ministre vous allez nous
faire un bilan bientôt ces jours-ci
peut-être aujourd'hui c'est à dire après
le vote ou demain je crois qu'il aurait
été beaucoup il serait beaucoup plus
pertinent pour un gouvernent pour un
parlement qui se respecte de discuter de
façon contradictoire des rapports
multiples que qui sortent ou qui vont
sortir sur le bilan et l'adresse de
l'adhérent que de la politique du
pouvoir et sur la délinquance avant de
se lancer dans une législation nouvelle
et de ce point de vue je trouve que au
fond l'autonomie du parlement est quand
même tout à fait limité pour ne pas dire
inexistantes
voilà puisqu'il suffit qu'on nous
demande qu'on vous demande de revoter
des lois encore toujours dans le même
sens toujours plus répressives pour que
vous répondiez comme un seul homme sans
vous interroger sur ce qui leur nient et
du bilan et de la délinquance
deuxièmement ce texte porte évidemment
un projet de société où domine le
contrôle social la surveillance
généralisée porte en germe des citoyens
dont d'ailleurs une grande part sera
confiée au privé ce qui évidemment tout
à fait dangereux à but très lucratif en
la matière un privé à but très lucratif
tandis que tous les acteurs sociaux de
prévention
sont en panne de moyens d'effectifs et
je dirais de considération ce qui est
très grave est évidemment inacceptable
enfin ce texte combiné avec le texte
ex besson c'est à dire le texte sur
l'immigration organisée organise
l'inégalité de droits entre les français
les étrangers sur notre territoire ce
qui est vraiment pas dans notre
tradition pour ceux qui se recouvrent
qui se réfère toujours à la tradition
républicaine et qui plus est on le verra
avec le futur texte entre eux mêmes les
français qu'ils soient de fraîche date
ou de l'ong plus longue date donc là on
est une rupture d'égalité en droits qui
est extrêmement aussi grave et
préoccupante d'ailleurs de la logique de
gouvernement de du pouvoir voilà donc
bien évidemment nous voterons comme en
première lecture contre ce texte et je
regrette que le débat ne soit pas plus
ouvert au parlement j'entends sur ces
questions mais elle fut même la mort ben
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
la deuxième lecture de ce projet de loi
dans notre haute assemblée n'aura pas
permis
loin s'en faut de lever les réelles
inquiétudes de la majorité des membres
du rds face à une politique sécuritaire
toujours plus dures inefficace et pour
tout dire injuste au gré de la navette
les dispositions de ce texte déjà très
hétérogène à l'origine se sont
transformés en un patchwork simplement
dictée par les aléas de la rubrique
faits divers des journaux
l'émotion est l' enquête d'opinion sur
devenu la principale source
d'inspiration de la politique pénale de
notre pays
or légiférer sous la coupe des médias
est non seulement absurde mais encore
créateur d'insécurité juridique et
d'injustice et pour tout
à l'opposé de la conception de l'intérêt
général que nous nous faisons cela était
largement rappelé durant nos débats les
magistrats comme les forces de l'ordre
sont excédés par cette politique
toujours plus sécuritaire qui leur
impose des objectifs inatteignables
au vu de la faiblesse des moyens qui
leur sont accordées et de la réduction
des effectifs que nous dénonçons à
chaque loi de finances
les statistiques montrent pourtant que
loin des incantations d'autosatisfaction
la délinquance n'a en rien reculé depuis
2002 et continue même à progresser de
façon inquiétante pour nos concitoyens
face à ce phénomène très complexe la
seule réponse du gouvernement est une
course en avant vers toujours plus de
répression d'aggravation des peines
d'enfermement 16 lois sécuritaires en
huit ans ne font pas une politique
pénale performante elle signe au
contraire un havre en constat d'échec
cette politique c'est celle des peines
plancher pour les primo-délinquants de
la double peine pour les étrangers du
renforcement de la rétention de sûreté
de la privatisation du domaine public de
la vidéosurveillance érigé en solution
passe par tous du couvre-feu pour
mineurs
cette politique nous la refusons
fermement par contre nous estimons comme
l'a brillamment défendu notre collègue
jacques mézard durant l'ensemble des
débats que la solution doit appréhender
l'ensemble des facteurs de délinquance à
commencer par les inégalités sociales de
plus en plus criante qui ne cesse
d'alimenter l'exclusion et la violence
ce qui ne nous empêche pas d'être
attaché au principe de responsabilité
individuelle et d'attendre de l'état une
grande fermeté quand cela s'impose
n'oubliez pas que les premières victimes
de la délinquance et de la criminalité
sont bien nos compatriotes les plus
défavorisés nous attendions également
une réflexion plus aboutie sur les
causes de la récidive
à commencer par le rôle qu'ils jouent au
l'état actuel de notre système carcéral
malgré la loi pénitentiaire
malheureusement ce projet de loi est
aveugle sur ce point le travail du sénat
et de notre commission des lois
a néanmoins permis de mieux répondre au
souci de respect des droits fondamentaux
auxquels nous sommes tous attachés
il est vrai aussi que l'assemblée
nationale s'est largement laissé
emporter dans le toujours plus
sécuritaire
monsieur le ministre un certain nombre
de nos amendements de certes été adopté
ce dont nous nous réjouissons
mais la philosophie de ce projet de loi
tel qu'il ressort de cette deuxième
lecture se situe fondamentalement à
l'opposé de notre conception de
l'intérêt général et de la justice la
majorité des membres du rdse votera donc
fermement contre je vous remercie
monsieur la mini vous devez demander
vous exprimer une explication de vote
vous avez la parole oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues donc nous arrivons au
terme de cette seconde lecture de la loi
loppsi 2 nous avions eu aussi en
septembre dernier un débat riche et et
danse
il était aussi du même ordre au cours de
cette seconde lecture qui ont aussi à
rendre hommage
j'irai au président de la commission des
lois au rapporteur ainsi qu'aux membres
de la commission des lois pour gérer le
travail de fond qui était fait je le dis
aussi avec mes collègues
j'irai qui font partie d'autres
commissions et je crois que c'est aussi
on a pu mesurer j'irai le travail
effectué alors au cours de l'examen de
en seconde lecture de ce texte important
parce que j'irai il touche complètement
une des préoccupations de nos
concitoyens se voir la sécurité sécurité
des personnes sécurité des biens
sécurité routière gérer lutte contre la
délinquance sous toutes ses formes gérer
on peut aussi parfois remettent en cause
certaines difficultés
mais j'irai c'est un combat collectif un
combat permanent tous les niveaux au
niveau de l'état des collectivités
territoriales puissent qu'on abordait
gendarmerie nationale police nationale
police municipale sécurité aussi privé
j'irai avec toutes les sociétés qui
interviennent
ou titre privé mais je dirais c'est un
travail de fond et les chiffres qui ont
été données par le monsieur le ministre
on font aussi montre aussi vraiment le
combat permanent permanent pour j'irai
lutter contre la délinquance sous toutes
ses formes
parce que je crois que la même durée
avec des techniques nouvelles des
technologies nouvelles comprend combien
entendu mais
à ce niveau là je tiens aussi à rendre
tiens aussi à rendre hommage au côté
humain parce que j'irai les les hommes
et les femmes qui travaillent au
quotidien pour la sécurité des personnes
et des biens sécurité routière je crois
que c'est c'est aussi un hommage qu'on
tient aussi à leurs données et les
dispositions qui sont prises en compte
en seconde lecture dont ce texte
important et fondamental montre aussi
une volonté du gouvernement
j'irai de faire avancer les choses et
d'améliorer constamment et aussi le lien
avec la justice parce que c'est une
grande chaîne avec plusieurs maillons el
roque c'est aussi et la sécurité en fait
partie donc je voudrais donc saluer tout
ce travail et qu'aucun système qui est
qui n'est parfait mais je pense que
moins 7 cette loi loppsi a le mérite
aussi de d'essayer de faire progresser
les choses sur leur pour lutter contre
la délinquance en général donc avec mes
goûts mes collègues du groupe ump
nous voterons cette loi loppsi 2 jours
merci madame boumediene oui monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je persiste
maintenant après ce débat à dire que ce
texte loppsi 2 développe une doctrine
celle qui privilégie les réponses
pénales spectaculaire criminalise qui en
fait poursuit une politique répressive
et inefficace au détriment de solutions
réfléchies mesurer pour de la véritable
prévention
en effet nous assistons et nous l'avons
dit lors de ces débats de plus en plus à
un durcissement inappropriée
inappropriée du droit pénal à une
méfiance de la magistrature
ce texte fourre tout législatif est
exclusivement répressif il porte
atteinte à nos libertés judiciaire à nos
libertés publiques et ne pouvons pas
l'accepter
en effet vous vous en prenez de plus en
plus aux familles les plus fragilisés
aux jeunes en difficulté vous
stigmatisez leurs parents en les
sanctionnant en les criminalisant au
lieu de donner les moyens d'affronter
les difficultés sociales
en fait aujourd'hui vous soldés oui vous
soldes et je sais c'est la période
malheureusement vous solder nos libertés
individuelles vous solder nos droits
vous autorisez les personnes morales
privées à installer des caméras aux
abords des établissements vous
permettait l'exploitation d'image vidéo
surveillance publique par des sociétés
privées
vous permettez le visionnage de faits et
gestes de nos citoyens dans les parties
communes d'immeubles vous privatiser la
sécurité vous déléguez les compétences
les d'un tas à des tiers faisant ainsi
l'aveu de notre incapacité à gérer les
problématiques sécuritaires françaises
nous sommes contre ces soldes en effet
vous atteignez la un point important il
est d'ailleurs un taux étonnant de
constater que un peu comme big brother
vous n'avez pas encore songé à imposer
le contrôle par watt gap du domicile de
chaque citoyen enfin et comme je l'aï
déjà dit je continuerai également dans
cet hémicycle mais aussi dans la rue aux
côtés des associations pour la liberté à
défendre à défendre ses libertés à
défend de cette justice que vous nous
refusez dans cette loi loppsi vous
voulez encore créer des peurs au travers
différentes mesures et lisible des
nouvelles incriminations dangereuse
inutile inapplicable
faisant toujours de la surenchère
sécuritaire et entre en tenant un
affichage purement médiatique et il me
semble électoralistes aujourd'hui nous
sommes face à une société qui je le
crains est en train de vivre une de
xénophobie ne win xénophobies politique
et en plus une certaine et xénophobe
excusez moi en effet cette loi
aujourd'hui est un recul et un recul par
rapport aux lois que nous avons
votée dans la loi pénitentiaire sur
l'aménagement des peines et un recul sur
nos principes d'individualisation par
les peines planchers et cette loi nous
inquiète elle nous inquiète parce que l
inverse les principes la liberté devient
exception l'enfermement devient la règle
alors aujourd'hui excusez nous de nous
vous le dire ne pourront pas vous suivre
sur 7 sur ce chemin
en effet nous sommes en train de
commencer à avancer vers de plus en plus
vers une attaque de notre nez percés de
notre démocratie et de nos libertés
et aujourd'hui la fois que j'ai dans
notre république n'est pas celle ci
merci bien
mais je reconnais alors nous arrivons au
terme de ce débat je vais mettre au
revoir l'ensemble du projet de loi ceux
qui sont favorables bien levé la main
merci avis contraire le projet de loi
est adopté
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat à
suivre sur notre antenne à partir de
midi les voeux de nicolas sarkozy aux
acteurs de la santé
très bonne journée à tous